hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde jetzt bitte alle
gemeinsam ich bin krank allerdings darf
ich euch heute dennoch herzlich
willkommen heißt und seiner neuen folge
sketch wohl mit der luther auf meinem
kanal allerdings nicht nur mit der luxus
sondern auch mit re wie ich weiß das war
auch meine reaktion da steht jedoch
allerdings bitte dass mein kopf immer
noch total dröhnt je länger ich vom pc
sitze von daher wird auch im heutigen
video weniger geschnittene als sonst ich
hoffe ihr habt dennoch spaß am video und
jetzt geht's los ich darf als erstes ein
wort auswählen ich nehme das sage ich
jetzt natürlich nicht laut
er ist erst mal hallo rollvi hallo luca
sag s wort warte mal hell wie soll man
das bezeichnen
es ist geschnitten haus ein schneck was
erwartete moment ist diese farbe würde
ich sagen ich weiß nicht was da mal ein
paar schicken späte keine raten hand
verband als aber an dass brown nicht
gelb mann deutschlands heja einer 26
buchstaben vater bin ich bescheuert oh
mein gott es ist gut es ist gut gemeint
es ist sehr gut gemalt um ein gott noch
so ein lasso alter er das ist richtig
gut gezeichnet irgendwas mit viel wasser
die zeiten
und
höhe
wasserkraft kreislauf gewicht alter oder
oder ist dass sein bild gleich ihm die
aufsatz oder so oder buch
[Musik]
keine ahnung was ist das eigentlich
wollte ich ganz geraten was ich habe
einfach gesagt ich hab's einfach
angetippt es war ins gericht ich habe so
gut ich habe es auch darum mein gott wie
meint er den hund schreibt wieder
irgendwas um sommer- winter- jahreszeit
sage ich das denn du spielst ja nicht
jünger vollidiot warum sage ich das denn
wir hatten der nächste streich oder
gemacht was soll das sein die kantigere
apfel isst du dumm alter hey das sagt so
ausfallend mit einem l am ende
brüssel rom ein kombi abgewinnen das
immer zu sagen du ja aber du hast das
ist ja eh schon vor mir das ist richtig
wie das werde die richtig schneller
raten mal steht oder gar nix was ist das
hey das kann man doch richtig sie
erraten den alten sondern sein was so ja
okay ich verstehe schon jaja unterstützt
[Musik]
war sein grundstück
warum gibt es denn keine hinweise so von
region man ist nah dran oder so steht
dann doch wenn man nah dran ist ja
welche schulart ist der gurke oder was
müssen wir noch nahe dran sein alter
hole ich was soll das sein revier
du sagst ich mal was du willst klassiker
das ist richtig gut wie ich bin richtig
begeistert von dir elliger ich bin
wirklich begeistert von einmal kennt von
einmal kenntnis nicht ich weiß wie du
was x naja dass da ganz klar das ist so
ampel das wort gesagt viel länger
irgendwie sind hier ist alles solche
maliger celica außer du das spiel spielt
einfach sarandon gerade drei buchstaben
gekloppt urplötzlich
das könnten das sein smartphone wird da
geraten im chatten badewanne drei wochen
später
das ist einfach scheiße gemalt warum das
alle gegeneinander gruppe pro b
wir sind einfach dumm bei den worten
alter hat man es erkennen können bei den
buchstaben sechsmal haben ich weiß es ja
gespenst oder oh mein gott es ist kein
gespenst yoshi's weg gegangen was
verpasst war ja sehr gut kannst mal der
geist alter aber wer aber welche quelle
sie bitte so aus dem die wehr gehen sie
nicht die die qualen mit augen und mund
die lächeln einfach so ein schwimmen die
tänzer das ist im wald oder warum krone
ja das ist ein
oh mein gott bist zu langsam junge ich
wollte jetzt holzfäller schreiben ja
wahrscheinlich ist dass der holzfäller
der der mitte zwischen den bäumen sich
aufgaben hat oder ich sagte oh mein gott
ich habe es natürlich so haben die da
saß mit am ende mit f am ende was ich
dachte das wär eine bowlingkugel und
dann hat er also eine kugel und dann hat
er der boni kugel gezeichnet sind wir so
blöd wie sind wir die einzigen mit fahne
tragen
wir sind
was ist das
ich frage mich einfach was manche leute
die wörter nicht richtig verstehen aber
danke für den fall dekker was haye
findet die leute in einer klasse und die
spielen das gerade weil da gibt es ja
wirklich gar nicht mehr kennt ihr
einfach gar nicht es ist hamburger
brötchen ich weiß nicht wo da irgendwas
mit ändern anfangen nürnberger muss ja
nun schon das könnte mir liegen lang
ist's her da ist findet safe mit den
leuten gar nicht wenn es eine nussschale
etwas richtig schwieriges
ja deshalb durchtrainierte eine
[Musik]
verstehst du ihr personal trainer oder
ja wie willst du ihn personenschützer
malen rasiert vorfilm sogar starke
rollvi du hast aber wieder raus du echt
starke muss den boden noch grün machen
dass das dann ist er wieder der meeres
kraft kreis nicht was sagen was sagt das
als schale aus
[Musik]
hatte vor allem warte des schiffes unter
wasser
aber sind wir so schlecht ins linken mal
ein pfeil nach unten
naja ok ok würde das wäre mein gott
das tier überhaupt nicht weiß nicht was
ist ein danke
das eine kelle war doch was
welches wort hat einen v am ende
ich schwöre ich kenne dieses wort mich
welche ecken slate bruder mein gott okay
ich kenne das wort noch schlecht aber
man hätte man hätte gemacht und man
hätte doch das den typen dort zu malen
sollen ja vor allem ich jetzt so typen
mit seiner brille und zum hut gemalt und
so ihren zug
wechsel wechsel am ende nein das junge
stark sv werth ist ich hätte erstmal
wasser gezeichnet oder das ist material
her gut was das sage ich mir sagst mir
schwer bitte wirtschaft schirm als
[Musik]
modedesigner alter erkennt das noch
richtig gut kennt die seitenkoffer nicht
mehr musste erst den neuen erkennen er
muss den neuen koffer sowie blödeste
ziel ja bitte
damals ja okay das war's oder was schon
ja schade also ganz knapp ist im alter
ganz klar das ding herzlichen
glückwunsch an finden der das ganze
gewonnen hat an der stelle wenn ich das
heute wieder jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
diese heutige folge sketch womit der
luchse und mit revierleiter gefallen hat
dann das gern einen daumen hoch und ein
bier gleich leider noch immer nicht
komplett fit in meiner birne weswegen
ich noch nicht so viel wieder
geschnitten habe am video und ich hoffe
dennoch dass ihr alle ein 1 1 1 1
nein
[Musik]